Uh,
[inaudible].
This video will continue to explore the sound system of Spanish as an example
for understanding phonology more generally.
Last time we looked at consonant and vowel phonemes and elephants.
This time we're going to work through the stress and syllable structure in Latin
American Spanish. Let's look at further sets of words in Spanish this time.
Paying attention not to the phonemes or did the ELA phones of those phonemes,
but to the stress
Si, Si. Oh, Kyla, Kyla. Oh, [inaudible].
Quinto. Guinta. I leave you. I leave you.
I leave you.
The words on the right hand side are marked with an asterisk and they don't
exist in Spanish.
So how does stress work in Spanish to push you in the right direction?
We find that accent plays some role in Spanish,
but moving the accent to a different syllable doesn't always generate a new
word. Some syllables are stressed,
but others are unstressed. Let's ask a more basic question.
How do syllables work in Spanish? In the IPA for language learning,
we looked at possible syllable types.
Now we move on to some examples that give us a sense of the fun, the tactics.
The syllable structure of Spanish a sparrow [inaudible] you'll see low say by
law. [inaudible]
may fall test to [inaudible] float.
I've given you examples of Spanish accentuation and syllable structure,
but what's going on here is accent contrasted in Spanish?
Meaning do we find minimal pairs that differ in accent placement? Only
reducing syllables to consonant and vowel.
What types of syllables exist in Spanish?
Please join me next time to start learning about rules and environments.
[inaudible] uh, [inaudible].